although the familiar formula is largely
intact pokemon sword and shield at a ton
of new features that shake up the
experience whether you're a beginner or
a veteran here are some useful tidbits
to keep in mind as you're exploring the
gallery region
[Music]
catching Pokemon works the same as it
always has but the types of Pokemon you
can find in the wild area can vary due
to location and most importantly whether
the wild area is divided into several
regions and weather will change from
region to region each day the types of
weather you encounter include rain
sandstorms and harsh sunlight and the
terrain types from Sun and Moon from
what we can tell the weather changes
every day so you'll want to revisit the
wild area often fortunately you don't
need to visit the wild area every time
you want to check the weather if you
open a town map you can hover over
different zones to see what the climate
is like or you can toggle weather on
with the plus button
[Music]
when you take your first steps in the
wild area you will most likely encounter
an Onix to the left what's odd about
this Onix is that it's off on its own
outside the tall grass in Pokemon sword
and shield if you see a pokemon
wandering around outside the grass that
usually means it's a high level Pokemon
nothing is stopping you from battling
these Pokemon right away but I would
advise caution if you aren't careful
many of these Pokemon can chew through
your party in a few moves
even if you do manage to whittle down
their HP you won't be able to catch them
until you have enough badges before you
venture out into the wild area we
recommend taking some polka dolls along
with you because these allow you to flee
without fail once you have a few gym
badges you'll want to return to the wild
area frequently so you can find and
catch these rare and powerful Pokemon
without digging into spoilers there are
some exciting and unexpected Pokemon you
can find in the wild area
Pokemon's sergeant shield also adds
camping before you get to the wild area
your mum will give you a camping set
this allows you to set up a tent play
with your Pokemon and cook curry
apart from being a heartwarming
diversion there are in-game benefits to
camping playing with your Pokemon will
strengthen your bond and net them some
experience points and if you need a
break from catching and battling then
maybe it's time to give your Pokemon a
well-earned rest
the highlight of the wild area are their
raid battles these battles allow you and
three other trainers both NPCs and real
players to battle and catch a Dynomax
Pokemon to initiate one of these you'll
need to find a den with a beam of light
shooting out of the ground once you and
your team knock out the Pokemon every
player is given one chance to catch it
from what we can tell the odds of
catching a red pokemon are fairly high
fortunately even if you don't catch the
Dynomax Pokemon you will get a bunch of
rewards including rare candies and XP
candies among other things early raid
battles can be completed by yourself
however they do get much tougher when
you start seeing four or five star raids
pop up we recommend finding a few
buddies with high-level Pokemon to join
you as these battles can require a fair
bit of coordination and preparation
[Music]
as you inspect Pokemon dens in the wild
area you will collect a currency called
Watts Watts can be traded to NPCs 40 ARS
which are basically single-use TMS
retro-style
and wishing pieces throw a wishing piece
into an empty den and voila a Pokemon
will appear and you can do a max raid
even if there's no beam of light
if you see a Pokemon with a yellowish
glow around it catch it right away it's
not shiny it's more powerful than normal
and that glow means it's generating
watts catching or defeating this Pokemon
will net you some watts but catching it
is better because these pokemon also
have some perfect stats
[Music]
while you can access your Pokemon boxes
from anywhere you'll want to hit up the
roto me PC in any pokemon center from
time to time this is the only way you
can access Pokemon jobs assignments you
can send your Pokemon on for experience
points and other minor rewards most of
these jobs are dependent on type like
sending a certain number of grass type
Pokemon to help some people out all you
need to do is pick the Pokemon decide
how long you want them gone and move on
with your day it's a great way to put
your box Pokemon to use so they don't
seem so lonely in there
Pokemon's sword and shield don't have
random encounters instead most Pokemon
walk around the overworld like they did
in let's go Pikachu and Eevee
however there are some Pokemon that will
pop up as an exclamation point in the
tall grass
these aren't totally random because you
have to walk up to them to interact with
them and start a battle but the Pokemon
you get will be random and there are
some Pokemon that can only be found
hidden in the tall grass like this those
are just a few tips to keep in mind as
you explore Galler
if you're still unsure which version to
pick up check out our video outlining
the key differences between sword and
shield for more Pokemon stay tuned to
game spot
[Music]
you